c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche et à toutes les fiches
qu'il a des pistonnés que s'ils font
sérieusement cet [ __ ] en photo une
photo de toi en train de dormir dans un
train elle est jaune avant oui ça j'ai
du mal à y croire
le maire
[Musique]
m
c'est un manager est bien l avis ou si
c'est moi qui cherchais le bien le
comportement qu'on pense que je suis un
comportement bah oui j'adore bien
comportement du pilote de gaza c'est
merveilleux c'est malicieux
j'ai mal aux yeux
[Musique]